what's your long-term aspirations what's
long-term
i think the ultimate vision the vision
of veritas has now evolved into
effectively being the answer to the
question what can i do so we we are a
catalyst for citizen empowerment so we
have uh as i sit here on my ipad right
now in front of you we have a team of
people that get tips from
uh dms from people instagram dms and
people call our hotline hundreds of
people a day message us and
people from all society you know
military people school nurses cops
honest firefighters
uh everyone and it's effectively
creating a mass movement
of these people on the inside of these
institutions to
to to blow the whistle i would i would
love to get more federal government
people to do that um the challenge we're
going to have with people inside the
federal government like ed snowden and
uh julian assange have shown us that
i think people are going to be
persecuted and and i think that people
are going to have to deal with that
persecution and prosecution um
so long term the answer to your question
is we want to create a mass movement of
whistleblowers
mass movement of which is lower
of these
whistleblowers yes
uh you and uh snowden have you guys ever
done anything together or no well funny
enough i was walking into your studio
literally through that massive bank
heavy heavy ass door
um
it's kind of heavy-handed
alan's been half asleep the whole time
now he's bossing out of all right so uh
what were you asking you were talking
about when you were walking in when i
was walking through this
incredible entrance to your studio here
with the bank door
snowden tweeted ed snowden tweeted a
video
of of our performance in miami the other
night uh ed snowden was tweeting about
the performance and and i have to say
about ed stone i
this is an example of this both sides
issue is that is he a hero is he a
villain
and i said when this happened not eight
years ago i thought about this because
i don't i think he defies
characterization you know he defies
characterization he what he exposed was
true james clapper lied under oath the
nsa director said we do not wittingly
you know spy on people is the worst liar
ever for a spook he was giving away all
the the gestures he was rubbing his brow
you're not supposed to do that bad spy
but he defies characters but the amount
of
pain you know and persecution he's had
to deal with he's in
russia
he's he's he's um
you can't live in the united states
otherwise he's going to be in you know
solitary confinement somewhere it's
going to require that level of sacrifice
and service and you might say well who
will ever do that
well
our service members go overseas and die
for their country
they do that
is there someone in washington dc
willing to make
willing to live in solitary confinement
for the rest of their life
for bringing disclosures to the public
showing what's actually happening inside
of an organization like the department
of justice is that someone is there a
human being
willing to do that
because i can show you
history is replete with millions of
people who who get killed
for this country
so
i i have a dream where there are people
that come out and hopefully they are not
prosecuted hopefully the disclosures are
such a degree
that that the people of this country say
you know what we're going to have their
back no matter what and we're going to
elect you out of office if you go after
those people
that that's that's my vision for the
future of this organization and you know
what sitting here right now today
i think it's going to happen so if you
enjoyed this little short segment from
the podcast that we did here's another
short segment to watch or if you want to
see the entire podcast click over here
take care everybody bye
[Music]